bonjour dominique imbert bon non merci
beaucoup d'être en direct avec nous ce
matin sur rtl france vous vous présentez
comme étant un combattant de la liberté
expliquez nous pourquoi
écoutez ça fait un certain nombre
d'années au moins 50 que je que je me
bats pour les libertés je suis par
ailleurs membre et président de
l'association environnementale dans les
vosges et lieu le début de cette crise
enrhumé g&g comment dire j'ai enfourché
mon bon mon cheval de bataille et puis
je me bats depuis contre le contre
l'ensemble des mesures liberticides qui
sont prises de façon permanente et
insidieuse et par par ce gouvernement
alors vous avez en plus eu un épisode
malheureux puisque votre oncle de 95 ans
a lieu elle se rendra à l'hôpital et on
lui a dit non parce qu'il n'avait pas ce
fameux pas sanitaire expliquez nous oui
absolument pas écouté il sortait il
sortait du séjour de fin de semaine à
l'hôpital il était rentré à la maison
ils devaient sus il devait passer une
visite de contrôle chez un neurologue à
l'hôpital d'epinal à la bêta du recale
et donc il est arrivé là où je ne lui
avais absolument pas prescrit de
saleté de présélection pour un test
contrairement à ce que raconte l'hôpital
la prescription pour le test a été faite
le jour même alors qu'on lui refusait
l'entrée on lui a dit voilà vous avez
une prescription pour un test
aujourd'hui démerdez vous bon je vais
excusez moi du terme à débrouillez vous
il était seul évidemment avec le
chauffeur devait s elle est en réalité
on l'a renvoyé chez lui c'est à dire
qu'il a dû faire 60 km en retour pour
venir à la maison vous imaginez le
stress pour une personne de son âge
enfin c'est absolument scandaleux quoi
ça dénote une une totale déshumanisation
de du système hospitalier
qui qui entraîne avec lui je veux dire
c'est que ce type de dérives qui est
qu'on n'aurait pas connu il y a plus il
ya deux ans absolument c'est une chose
pareille
oui pardon il fait donc partie votre
votre patron fait donc partie des douze
personnes au delà de 65 ans qui ne sont
toujours pas vaccinées en france
alors mon oncle et ma
bouche personnes 12% de 2 à
10 415 et non
oui bah écoutez il ya en réalité à
l'hôpital il a été vaccinée à une
première dose de vaccin et cela
d'ailleurs contre mon gré enfin moi
j'avais demandé qu'on me prévienne à la
vente on ne l'a pas fait et évidemment
convaincre un homme de 95 en situation
de faiblesse sion plus commence à perdre
un peu la tête et filer à c'était assez
facile pour les médecins donc ils l'ont
acquis mais voilà comme ça sans réalité
sans lui demander son avis parce qu'il
n'avait pas en réalité les moyens de
décider voilà je pense que la moindre
des choses utilité de ce
[Musique]
pour quoi je peux vous demander pourquoi
vous voulez pas que votre enfant soit
vacciné dans l'écouté bon des raisons
que vous connaissez parce qu'on
reconnaît les risques de ceux de cette
injection dire si la 95 ans il est dans
une
fente est extrêmement fragile il a passé
cinq semaines à l'hôpital je ne vois pas
l'intérêt de le vacciner quand on
connaît l'efficacité redoutable de sévaz
de choses qu'il y en a à peu près aucune
je pense que c'est inutile de rajouter
un risque supplémentaire sur la tête
d'une personne qui est qui qui est déjà
atteint j'imagine que vous protégez
votre oncle évidemment votre oncle vivi
à domicile tout à fait il lui dans la
même maison quoi on le il est maintenu à
domicile grâce à toute une série
d'intervenants infirmières aides
soignantes et settat et
nous faisons le maximum pour qu'ils
restent à la maison voilà nous avons une
maison un appartement voilà ils vivent à
côté les uns des autres et donc vous
estimez suffisamment responsables pour
l'écarter du danger ben je pense oui je
pense en tout cas je le souhaite exercer
cette responsabilité le plus retenu le
mieux possible
quand l'accès a été refusé à votre grand
père à l'hôpital
quelle va être la suite finalement est
ce que vous avez décidé de porter
plainte est ce que vous allez faire
vacciner que parce qu'il va bien falloir
un jour qu'il y retourne à l'hôpital
écoutez il n'est pas oubliés ils ont
valu on va fils retourne à l'hôpital on
lui on fera un test un frein des
spéciales et déjà un test extrêmement
extrêmement invasif je ne comprends pas
pourquoi je ne comprends pas pourquoi on
plutôt que je suis beau d'or les raisons
pour lesquelles on refuse de faire le
test salivaire est aussi efficace que le
test pcr et qui est beaucoup moins
invasif et et qui pourrait être fait
très facilement et enfin au pire au pied
voilà il sera un test epfr et qu'est ce
que vous pensez que d'autres personnes
s'en sont dans son cas depuis que vous
avez subi cette refus est ce que vous
vous êtes renseigné ce que d'autres
personnes sont dans son cas
pas ma connaissance en tout cas pour
l'instant mais vous savez le problème
c'est que peu de gens parlent c'est que
nous nous avons fait dit nous avons été
informés nous avons mon épouse et moi
même rédigé un courrier une lettre
ouverte aux citoyens de ce pays
également intitulé comme ça dans
laquelle on raconte cette histoire et
les combien de gens parlent raconte
exprime s'exprime il ya une une forme de
peur générale dans ce pays qui a été
instaurée par par cette politique
aujourd'hui les médecins eux-mêmes enfin
en tout cas la majorité des médecins est
quasiment totalement lobotomisés les
appliquent des directives
dont certaines font totalement la france
et ils ne font plus marcher leur la leur
réflexion ils n'ont plus le droit de
prescrire depuis le début de ces trucs
et sanitaires nhtsa précise ce qu'on
leur dit pas fuir il doit on leur dit
rien d'autre c'est absolument c'est tout
à fait autre envie d'une situation d'une
gravité extrême aujourd'hui et le drame
c'est que le système de logo
stabilisation de la population est en
train de fonctionner heureusement encore
il ya des gens qui résistent j'espère
qu'ils font de plus en plus nombreux les
amis on les a vus devant le sénat hier
soir vous comptez sur les sénateurs pour
tenter de limiter en tout cas là est la
portée de ce pass sanitaires ils veulent
imposer dans les territoires où il ya le
plus de risques est ce que c'est une
meilleure idée
écoutez le plus de 15 ans a laissé
naître une
conscience est extrêmement relative est
le même des combats pour la liberté
depuis depuis que j'ai 15 ans et dans
les années 70 aujourd'hui
j'ai je ne crois pas que les élus
sénateurs haute soit en capacité de
changer grand chose bon en plus à la cie
des institutions ne permettra aux
sénateurs de bloquer complètement un
projet de loi si le gouvernement veut le
faire passer il finira par le faire
passer avec les qu'en dira que les jus à
l'assemblée où on va où par ordonnance
tout simplement
merci beaucoup dominique mercy beaucoup
dominique imbert de nous avoir livré
votre témoignage soit ce matin en direct
sur rt france